San Diego comic-con 2019 has brought big
news for fans of the greenest girl in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe thanks to
a panel discussion with Avengers end
game writers Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely as well as directors Joe
and Anthony Russo we finally have an
answer to a huge question about the post
endgame fate of Gamora a fan favorite
member of the guardians of the galaxy of
course some questions will always remain
unanswered
Wiress Gamora according to Vanity Fair
Markus and McFeely revealed that Zoe
Saldana's
alien assassin is indeed alive and well
in the aftermath of Tony Stark's
momentous snap at the end of endgame the
one that completely took out Thanos's
army of evildoers and creepy creatures
some fans were concerned that they may
have permanently lost Gamora
- Tony snapped considering that thanks
to some time-travel antics Avengers
endgame featured a past version of
Gamora who is still working with her
adoptive father
Thanos Marvel fans don't need to be
reminded of present-day Kimora's
emotional death in Avengers infinity war
where Thanos sacrificed her to snag the
soul stone and power his Infinity
Gauntlet during his quest for universal
domination watching her lose her life an
infinity war was difficult and thinking
that past Gamora was a goner as well
after the events of endgame was even
more devastating to consider ever since
her first appearance in guardians of the
galaxy Sal ganas Gamora has charmed
audiences thanks to her intense fighting
prowess her sharp wit and intelligence
and of course her romantic entanglement
with Peter quill there's another name
you might know me by
star-lord who however star-lords fury
over his fall in love is one of the
factors that led to fan OSes snapping at
the clothes of infinity war in the first
place
when quill emotionally attacked Thanos
after learning the news of gamora's
death it gave the supervillain the
opportunity to overpower the Avengers
and ultimately snap away half of all
life across the entire universe five
years after that OSes fateful decimation
the Avengers reunited an endgame to
attempt a time heist in hopes of saving
all of their vanquished friends and
loved ones despite several mishaps it
ended up working out but one surprise
guest returned along with everyone else
who was originally dusted when Thanos
shot his army from 2014 into the MC use
present Gamora was suddenly back in play
with a big catch this wasn't the version
of Gamora that died in infinity war
rather it was the 2014 Gamora who was
still firmly on her dad's side
for this reason fans debated whether or
not Gamora was spared during Tony
Stark's sacrificial snap during end
games big battle scene even though it
was possible that Tony snapped didn't
dust her and that she was still around
somewhere Gamora didn't show up on
star-lords radar when he went searching
for her in the final moments of endgame
the argument was still raging in May of
2019 when the creative team behind
Avengers end game simply stoked the
flames by saying that gamora's fate
could go either way during a chat with
Business Insider the Russo said that
Gamora may have been dusted but it was
also possible that she survived the snap
they then stated that fans would just
have to wait until guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 arrives and theaters to see
for themselves to make matters more
stressful the Russos also said that
quill who is looking for Gamora at the
end of endgame didn't know what had
happened to her either at that time the
Russo brothers seemed happy to put the
burden of this particular reveal on
James Gunn who is returning as the
writer and director of the third
guardians movie but thankfully they've
changed their tune and revealed the
truth ahead of schedule however now that
we know for sure that Gamora is alive
there are still some obvious
complications since she's the 2014
Gamora she doesn't know anything about
the Avengers and
doesn't really know who Peter quill even
is which could present some pretty
awkward problems
she and her sister nebula could also
still potentially be at odds despite the
friendship they forged throughout their
previous adventures together
Saldana hasn't officially confirmed her
return in Guardians three but she did
recently say that she would love to play
a more villainous version of her
signature Marvel character in the
upcoming sequel so it stands to reason
that Gamora would be included in the
final film of this whimsical irreverent
film trilogy and since she was also one
of the stars who petitioned to reinstate
Gunn after old tweets initially got him
fired from the third guardians film the
idea of Gunn not being behind the camera
is no longer standing in the way of her
returning for now it remains to be seen
just what type of role Gamora will play
in the upcoming Marvel films but at the
very least it's comforting to know that
the MCS favorite verdant warrior is
still out there somewhere planning her
next move check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the MCU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]